in poker sometimes my gut is right but
sometimes it's wrong there's an error
rate inherent in my in in my intuition
and we should maybe talk about that and
I think this I can imagine this is the
case with others as well I I wouldn't go
so far to say as I was disparaging of
the gut but I called for moderation like
there are things that I'll gut is good
for and there are things that it's
definitely not B go on so what you're
raising is a very difficult problem
which is a failure rate yes of our gut
so now we're left standing going well
then when do I trust my gut and what
you're a for is well trust the math at
least you know what the failure rate is
now i' I would say I've swung back in
the other direction again and think that
there is almost like some kind of shared
knowledge going on that we can tap into
like and once I became open to the idea
that you can sort of almost tap into
some borderline Supernatural realm of
inspiration I've started having way more
inspiration